[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à tous nous sommes
dans parlement hebdo l'émission qui
revient sur les séquences fortes à
l'assemblée et au sénat est notre invité
pour commenter la semaine parlementaire
jérôme bignon bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur les indépendants de la somme
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
merci de m'avoir invité alors jérôme
bignon va commencer par vous présenter
vous êtes né à neuilly-sur-seine vous
avez 70 ans et vous êtes sénateur de la
somme depuis 2014
auparavant vous étiez député vous avez
parcouru les couloirs de l'assemblée
pendant 14 ans homme de droite vous êtes
passés de l air à agir en 2017 agir
c'est la droite constructive un
vis-à-vis du gouvernement
aujourd'hui vous fait d'ailleurs partie
du groupe les indépendants au sénat
votre sujet de prédilection jérôme
bignon basse et l'environnement vous
étiez d'ailleurs le monsieur coop 21 du
sénat on se le rappelle alors que la
coop 25 s'achève comment jugez-vous
aujourd'hui ces grandes rencontres
internationales sur le climat
est ce que pour vous ça sert encore
vraiment à quelque chose ah oui c'est
indispensable si on se recueillit plus
on n'avance pas c'est même la condition
aussi le problème c'est que c'est très
lourd très compliqué très technique très
difficile à comprendre pour tout le
monde y compris pour ceux qui
participent de plus un seul entre voici
les résultats un peu décevants par
rapport à l'urgence climatique notamment
aimé l'urgence ne va pas avec la
facilité à résoudre des problèmes
complexes si c'est urgent c'est vrai
c'est absolument urgent c'est déjà
formidable que la prise de conscience de
l'urgence et est maintenant c'est se
soit emparée de tout le monde les jeunes
y ont beaucoup contribué mais les
personnes plus anciennes sont concernés
mais ça ne résout pas ça ne rend pas
facile le problème l'urgence ne rend pas
facile le règlement du problème
jérôme bignon on va dérouler l'actualité
avec vous beaucoup d'actualité à
commencer par la réforme des retraites
qui sera examiné au parlement fin
février débat show en perspective l'âge
d'équilibré fixé à 64 ans alimente la
colère la loi anti gaspillage en
discussion à l'assemblée les députés ont
voté la fin des plastiques à usage
unique d'ici à 2040
et puis la suite des auditions de la
commission d' enquête du sénat sur
l'accident de lubrizol échanges tendus
vous allez le voir alors que le site a
eu l'occasion l'autorisation de rouvrir
et on commence avec un sujet
incontournable cette semaine les
retraites
[Musique]
alors que le premier ministre a dévoilé
les contours de la réforme mercredi un
sujet braque les syndicats et a fait
rentrer la cfdt dans la grève
l'âge pivot à 64 ans du côté de la
droite sénatoriale
mais problème c'est plutôt le
financement cécile 6o la question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
et concerne également la réforme des
retraites mercredi philippe dallier a
bien écouté les annonces d'edouard
philippe sur la réforme des retraites et
aux questions d'actualité il est revenu
vers le premier ministre pour avoir des
précisions sur deux mesures en
particulier les 1000 euros de pension
minimum et les compensations pour les
retraites des enseignants
vous n'avez rien dit monsieur le premier
ministre du coup des mesures de
transition et des mesures nouvelles ni
de la manière dont vous allez les
finances et voilà ma question pour
régler le problème qui va être posée aux
enseignants qui eux risque effectivement
de perdre beaucoup en termes de pensions
si jamais leur traitement n'est pas
augmenté de manière significative
ça va avoir un coût de combien c'est la
question que je posais j'ai pas eu de
réponse
edouard philippe avait bien dit qu'il
donnerait des réponses fermes et
définitives mais la compensation du
manque à gagner estimé à 10 milliards
d'euros pour la retraite des profs ne
semble pas encore complètement clair
pour le gouvernement
on a dit on démarre une négociation donc
une négociation sur les rémunérations au
premier semestre 2020 on veut qu'elle
soit achevée à l'été 2020 et à partir de
là on pourra dire la date à laquelle on
le fait et ce n'est pas tout le
gouvernement ne semble pas non plus
totalement convaincu par le choix qu'il
a fait pour équilibrer le système des
retraites dans son ensemble il a choisi
de mettre en place un âge d équilibre à
64 ans mais le problème c'est la ligne
rouge d'un des seuls syndicats qui
soutient la réforme du gouvernement
la cfdt au manifeste très clairement
parce que on veut d'abord la retrait de
cette mesure d'agen j libre et on veut
rediscuter de l' équilibre c'est pas une
question taboue pour nous rediscuter le
gouvernement se dit prêt à la
négociation si les partenaires sociaux
proposent des alternatives
slash déquilibre les modalités pour
parvenir à l'équilibré financier
c'est négociable sur twitter edouard
philippe a indiqué qu'il allait
contacter les
d'heure syndicaux pour reprendre le
dialogue jérôme bignon la cfdt avait
prévenu depuis le début que fixer un âge
pivot on parle d'âge de kylie mais c'est
un peu la même chose ça c'était sa ligne
rouge
est ce que le gouvernement en ayant
parlé de sa tâche d'équilibrer joue avec
le feu dont il continue dans sa logique
qui est de dire il faut non seulement
faire une retraite plus juste mais une
retraite qui soit supportable
financièrement et l'âge des clips c'est
un moyen d'y arriver parce que il ya des
choses qui sont qu'il faut regarder il
ya 40 ans il y avait quatre actifs pour
un retraité aujourd'hui à 1,7 actifs
pour un retraité dans l'europe entière
tous les pays équivalent au nôtre
l'allemagne la belgique le danemark et
de la suède des pays qui ont des niveaux
de vie équivalent au nôtre
ils travaillent tous deux trois quatre
ans de plus que nous parfois donc on ne
peut pas s'en trouver sans faire un
effort financier tous le problème c'est
que cet effort soit partagé ce que vous
dites c'est donc ce que cette tâche
d'équilibrer c'est la promesse pour tout
le monde ne travaille plus longtemps et
donc de cotiser plus longtemps pour
financer ce régime des retraites qui je
le crains en déficit je regrette
beaucoup pour les gens qui sont obligés
de travailler plus longtemps
enfin c'est pas un bagne de il ya des
gens pour qui c'est dur
et à ce moment là il faut envisager
comme le gouvernement l'a fait de revoir
les clauses de pénibilité à avoir un
bonus pour les carrières longues pouvoir
partir en cas en cas de difficultés de
santé aider les femmes qui ont des
carrières hachées et c'est donc tout ça
c'est pris en compte mais c'est un peu
oublié dans le débat mais du coup et
d'un ça mais les syndicats réformistes
dans la rue alors pourvu que oui on est
donc dans une situation de blocage total
alors qui est aujourd'hui responsable de
cette situation pour vous ce sont les
syndicats ou c'est aussi le gouvernement
qui a voulu vraiment avancer si le débat
était facile ça se saurait donc on n'a
pas fait j'ai que vous avez évoqué le
fait que j'étais parlementaire depuis
assez longtemps
j'ai connu quelques j'étais là en 90 et
en 95
j'étais là sous la réforme fillon sur
les formes sarkozy etc
je peux je n'ai pas de souvenir
formidable deux de ces périodes où on
marche beaucoup à paris voilà c'est très
difficile puis on finit toujours par
trouver des accommodements parce que les
français sont bagarreur mais sois là
justement comment vous voyez la sortie
de l'impasse train censé bloquer bien
reprendre la négociation commence ici
tout le monde va faire un effort puisque
tout est négociable
le ministre de l'économie a dit à un
instant à votre antenne que finalement
si les syndicats avaient d'autres
solutions à proposer le gouvernement
était à l'écouté pour le pour eux pour
aller dans leur sens il a
particulièrement au niveau de cet âge
pivot mais c'est à dire là dessus il
faut pas faux pas leurrer les français
sur le problème de l'âge pivot parce que
si c'est un problème qui est inéluctable
il faut que les gens regardent les
choses en face on travaille plus tard on
commence à travailler plus tard parce
que les gens sont éduqués quel que soit
le niveau de formation qui tel cas
jusqu'aux la formation qu'ils aient
choisi ça prend du temps ont recommencé
à travailler une partie des gens qui
travaillent à 14 ans puis après 16 ans
puis 18 ans mais aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt 20 ans le début 22 ans donc il ya
il ya une évolution sociétale qui fait
qu'il faut la prendre en compte
sans ça on ne pourra pas assumer le
paiement un mois jérôme bignon sur
l'objection important au sein de la
droite sénatoriale
on a entendu philippe dallier dans le
reportage qui dit ça va être aussi
synonyme de coûts supplémentaires cette
réforme entre la valorisation des
salaires pour les enseignants la pension
minimum à 1000 euros
est ce que c'est la meilleure des choses
à faire lorsque justement en charge
reste monsieur alliés pour vous ne
voudrais pas qu'on donne un minimum de
1000 euros aux gens qui n'ont pas eu
1000 euros sur les agriculteurs les
commerçants des artisans vont être
sensible à son attention
est ce que monsieur d'allier ne voudrais
pas qu'on donne aux femmes qui à partir
du premier enfant de données à partir du
troisième je crois que pour que la
réforme marche il faut qu'elle soit
juste équitable et que faut il faut
absolument qu'on intègre les plus
démunis les plus les moins favorisés
dans cette dans cette réforme il faut
donner confiance aux jeunes qui croient
qu'ils ne croient pas qu'ils auront une
retraite au dur oui ils ont une retraite
si nous faisons cet effort puisque les
pays équivalent au nôtre dans le au sein
de l'union européenne donc avec lesquels
nous avons des économies des six thèmes
sociétaux très proche
l'on fait et ne sens où je ne porte pas
plus mal surtout qu'il faut le savoir
ils travaillent plus longtemps et ils
ont des retraites moins importante que
celle qu'on propose à nos salariés en
france
non je pense qu'on travaillera un peu
plus longtemps ça fait partie du jeu
j'ai 70 ans
j'ai trahi je suis toujours en activité
j'ai commencé à travailler à 23 ans donc
ça fait quand même un paquet d'années
je suis assez en forme mon corps donc
c'est pas impossible de travailler je
comprends bien que il a travaillé
parlementaire c'est plus facile de
physiquement que de travailler à la
chaîne ou travailler à la caisse d'un
supermarché géant convient j'en conviens
bien volontiers mais il faut qu'on s'il
faut considérer mais dans la vie qui
vient on travaillera un peu plus
longtemps
alors mercredi soir jérôme bignon le
premier ministre a retrouvé les députés
de la majorité à l'assemblée pour parler
de cette réforme des retraites
pas forcément tous rassurés les déboutés
écouter d'abord le président du groupe
alain m gilles legendre et monique limon
qui est député et qui s'inquiète de
certaines mesures
écoutez c'est au micro de céline crespy
cette réforme c'est notre réforme et
nous voulons absolument la mener jusqu'à
son terme
nous savons que c'est difficile la
difficulté est à la hauteur de
l'ambition
une ambition réformatrice de notre
protection sociale
comme il n'y en a jamais eu depuis 1945
donc c'est normal que ça pose des
difficultés c'est normal que ça fasse
trébucher un certain nombre de relations
de négociations
nous ne reculerons en aucun cas sur
cette réforme il ya des petites choses
quand même qu'on aimerait bien voir et
qu'on ne voit pas par exemple par
exemple ça reste pension de réversion
pour les peaux les gens mariés
on aimerait bien pacs est quand même
dans l'air du temps quoi peut-être
revoir un petit peu les 5% là du premier
enfant est ce que ça pourrait pas être
un forfait ce qu'enfin on réfléchit à
des à des choses comme ça si on veut
vraiment ça revienne à un plus pour les
femmes et moi j'aimerais bien que ça
soit un plus pour les femmes
peut-être qu'il ya encore des choses à
travailler ça va être notre job de
parlementaires de le faire voilà pour
ces réactions globalement jérôme binet
ce que les femmes seront gagnante ou
perdante avec cette réforme est ce que
vous
vous devez répondre à cette question
j'espère qu'elles le seront j'ai compris
que c'était l'idée du gouvernement j'ai
compris qu'ils avaient des mesures très
positives qui allaient dans le sens par
exemple pas citer on en doute même au
sein de la majorité
mais bon c'est les députés ont toujours
peur ce qui est légitime parce que ils
sont en contact direct avec le suffrage
universel
ils se disent y aura des élections me le
reprochera et ses terrasses qui est
probablement les sénateurs ont un peu
plus de recul parce que leurs
interlocuteurs sont les élus locaux qui
sont moins réactif moins violemment
réactif que que le mais on voit bien
monsieur légende qui dit on tient la
députée est dans son rôle d'essayer de
trouver des solutions plus fine plus
riches
je crois que le maître mot en fait c'est
qu'on est dans une période de
négociation qui va être dur
ils ont chacun le premier ministre et le
leader de la cfdt pris des positions
assez solide assez ferme assez arrêté
mais les hommes sont intelligents et
dont ils m'ont santons et on a également
un début de calendrier parlementaire sur
cette réforme on va voir un certain
nombre de dates mais il va y avoir un
débat sur les retraites le 7 janvier au
sénat une séance de questions à
l'assemblée le 22 janvier présentation
du projet de loi en conseil des
ministres texte qui arrive au parlement
février la fin du débat parlementaire
normalement et l'adoption du texte et
pour l'été est ce que c'est pour vous un
bon timing
il ya une sacrée accélération après les
18 mois de concertation je trouve que
une fois que le débat les termes du
débat sont posées il faut trancher il
faut y aller qu'est-ce que je devrais de
parler des années de plus
il ya un temps pour les propositions il
va y avoir un temps pour trouver ce
qu'on appelle un deal une transaction il
faut il faut se mettre d'accord qu'il
n'y ait pas de perdant que personne ne
perde la face
je pense qu'il ya les éléments du de
sueur dans les éléments du dossier il ya
de quoi trouver une solution il faut que
les gens soient soit gagnant tous soient
rassurés parce que effectivement on a
fait naître des craintes et le
calendrier me paraît légitime mais
raisonnable pour aboutir à une loi qui
n'est pas d'une complexité
invraisemblable alors que les termes
sont posées on peut s'attendre quand
même à une montagne d'amendements sur ce
grand test
ici ça fait partie du grand débat qu'a
laissant chacun à sa bonne idée a
raconté sa touche pour apporter sa
modification
ça ça fait partie du jeu parlementaire
et c'est bien le droit d'amendement et
imprescriptible est ce que pour vous
jean paul delevoye est encore l'homme de
la situation pour porter ce texte lui
même a déclaré qu'il avait pensé à
démissionner cette semaine pour ne pas
fragiliser la réforme après notamment et
bien les révélations sont re son cumul
de fonctions incompatibles entre un
poste dans le privé sa fonction au
gouvernement ça fragilise quand même ça
ça c'est sûrement ça ne ça n'est pas un
moment facile à vivre pour lui je
l'imaginent puisque j'étais en classe
avec jean paul delevoye avait ou que
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié pour lui donc
vous me permettrez de le soutenir dans
cette épreuve et de ne pas dire autre
chose
très bien et bien c'est entendu on va
changer de thème jérôme bignon lutter
contre le gaspillage et valoriser
l'économie circulaire c'est l'objectif
du projet de loi actuellement en débat à
l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
le texte occupera les députés jusqu'à
noël cette semaine les députés ont
notamment voté un amendement au projet
de loi qui prévoit la fin des emballages
plastique à usage unique d'ici à 2040
explications de fanny die le plastique à
usage unique pourrait bien disparaître
d'ici à 2040
c'est l'amendement compte adopter les
députés en début de semaine lors de
l'examen du projet de loi de lutte
contre le gaspillage
l'amendement issus de la majorité
soutenue par le gouvernement prévoit une
grande concertation sur le sujet avant
nous avons donc avoir un plan qui soit
concret qui est fait des preuves qui
soit ambitieux qui soit réaliste avec
une vraie méthode qui va permettre de
définir avec avec les filières
industrielles et je sais combien de ce
côté ci en particulier de l'hémicycle c
est une inquiétude et un souci avec les
associations de consommateurs aussi et
avec les associations de protection de
l'environnement des plans à 5 ans avec
des objectifs réalistes et des solutions
crédibles
le but programmé la fin de la mise sur
le marché des plastiques à usage unique
emballages alimentaires flacons de
produits de beauté aux bouteilles de
shampoing seront progressivement
interdit jusqu'à leur disparition totale
d'ici à vingt ans la trajectoire devrait
être précisée tous les cinq ans et
s'accorde avec l'objectif d'atteindre
100% des plastiques recyclés d'ici à
2025 sur les bancs de la droite la
mesure inquiète ce sont des pans entiers
de l'économie française qui vont
terriblement souffrir et ça on n'en
parle pas suffisamment on n'en parle pas
on ne parle pas des emplois supprimés on
ne parle pas des territoires fragilisés
on ne parle pas des entreprises qui
devront parce que la reconversion ça
n'est pas si simple
et je trouve que c'est le grand absent
de nos débats dès 2021 couvert paille et
autres plastiques du quotidien devraient
disparaître en france et dans toute
l'union européenne
le gouvernement a t-il raison de
programmer la fin des des plastiques est
ce que 2040 c'est un horizon trop
lointain où 17 heures à mon point de vue
je suis très engagé sur l'océan depuis
très longtemps j'ai prise et l'agencé
des aires marines protégées
jugé par principe à une petite
association sur mon territoire qui
s'appelle
sos laisse de mer et on ramasse
intervalles réguliers sur les plages du
littoral picard des tonnes de plastique
c'était pouvant table sur le plan finot
problème pour les milieux c'était
épouvantable pour les poissons ce sont
des perturbateurs endocriniens
ce que dit taha ce matin j'avais la
région de la plateforme au scion iq
l'image et vous m'avez invité je n'ai
pas pu y aller mais c'est quelque chose
qui est essentiel à l'union contre le
plastique donc il faut trouver les
moyens bon sens dans 20 ans on voit des
satellites des fusées sur saturne et on
n'est pas capable de résoudre le
problème du classique via un truc qui va
pas vous faut il ya trop d'argent
probablement au soutien du plastique
pour que nos vies derrière ça va
sûrement il ya toujours des lobbys en
soit c'est pas je comprends que les gens
qui font du plastique soit défendre
leurs intérêts c'est légitime mais le
pouvoir le le la responsabilité des
pouvoirs publics c'est dire ok vous avez
profité maintenant vous investissez pour
trouver autre chose il faut massivement
investir dans la science pour trouver
des substituts au plastique certains
députés comme annie genevard
s'inquiètent de l'application de cette
maison à ce que vous comprenez je peux
le comprendre parce qu'il ya peut-être
une usine de bouteilles en plastique sur
son dans son département il ya peut-être
un problème de dos d'eau minérale dans
son département je sais je connais pas
la syrie la situation locale mais je les
ai entendus au sénat dans d'autres
débats ou que telle ou telle disait moi
j'ai ça va mettre à la rue des deux
ouvriers qui font des bouteilles de
plastique
ok mais on a mis à la rue
malheureusement si c'était les premiers
qu'on mettait à la rue je comprends
qu'on soit
désolé mais il ya malheureusement
l'évolution industrielle du monde fait
que quand on a on va arrêter de faire
les voitures diesel on va arrêter de
faire des dires du moteur diesel ceux
qui les font on est obligé de se
recycler donc pour vous il faudrait
faire ça dans quel délai parce que quand
aux abois une part sont dix à vingt ans
c'est un signal fort et concret vous
dites bien bon bah c'est trop tard pour
vous cinq ans ça me paraît longue mais
je ne suis pas scientifique
donc je serais tenté de dire le plus
vite possible ce qu'il faudrait c'est
pas donné à délaisser de fixer demandé à
des scientifiques de prendre le dossier
en main demander à des gens compétents
de dire dans combien de temps vous
pensez qu'on peut construire un projet
industriel mais c'est un projet qui
devrait être menée à l'échelon
européenne et on est tous concernés
les allemands sont aussi concernés que
nous la planète est concerné puisque les
océans sont un vaillant valley de
produits plastiques que nous allons
manger pendant des siècles et qui font
des quilles ont des effets sur la santé
j'aurais fertilité et sur la critique
très vite il ya une autre point dans ce
texte qui fait débat la consigne est ce
que vous avez compris quelque chose au
système de consigne que le gouvernement
ferait pour les bouteilles en verre si
je suis pas toujours d'accord avec la
majorité du sénat mais là j'étais assez
d'accord avec elle et mes collègues de
nerfs mes anciens amis méga riches
j'ai encore de très bons terre
comprenait les inquiétudes des
collectifs investi énormément et on leur
on les a poussés à le faire dans des
centres de tri dans le traitement des dd
des déchets et notamment des bouteilles
de plastique on leur dit maintenant tout
ce que vous avez fait non seulement vous
allez continuer de payer les asiles et
des échéances d'emprunt mais ensuite on
va vous on va vous piquez la marchandise
cohérent pour vous abandonner sa part
est on là et on a essayé d'expliquer à
madame poirson mais elle n'a pas voulu
beaucoup de l'entente le projet du
gouvernement du coup pour vous ce n'est
pas une bonne mesure il est dur de
l'assemblée nationale de trouver une
équipe de mener une expérimentation
ça n'est pas pour mettre le la poussière
sous le tapis
c'est parce que véritablement il faut
regarder comment ça se produit comment
ça se déroule qu'est ce que ça a comme
effet et comment on peut faire pour
il ressort que les collectivités au ps
vous pas s'étonner que le sénat
défendent des collectivités yanncik son
sénatoriales au mois de septembre
et en plus c'est beau c'est siri sionnel
arseo du coeur de métier voilà
aujourd'hui mon rôle a été élu par des
collectivités
jérôme bignon va passer au dernier sujet
de cette émission la commission d'
enquête sur leur idole dont vous faites
partie poursuit ses auditions au sénat
[Musique]
et on va s'intéresser particulièrement à
une audition celle des représentants de
normandie logistique usine mitoyenne de
lubrizol jeudi et que se sont posés on
victime face aux sénateurs une posture
qui a mis à l'épreuve la patience des
parlementaires flora sauvages alors que
le conseil départemental de
l'environnement et des risques
sanitaires a donné son feu vert pour la
réouverture du site lubrizol à rouen les
sénateurs tentent de lever le voile sur
les dysfonctionnements qui ont conduit à
l'incendié de 26 septembre dernier
auditionné devant la commission denquête
le directeur de normandie logistique
l'entreprise mitoyennes ou lubrizol
stocker une partie de ces fûts réfute
toute responsabilité
on se considère comme une victime
souhaite cet incendie on l'a on l'a
répété plusieurs fois mais je dirais que
pour nous il est impossible que la 110e
président chez nous contrairement à
lubrizol l'entreprise normandie
logistique n'était pas classé seveso
mais elle stocker des produits de
lubrizol entreprises classées seveso
seuil haut
donc je vais peut-être vous êtes
peut-être bouc émissaire mais vous avez
quand même semble-t-il si j'en crois
l'arrêté de la dréal commis quelques
mots court pour reprendre un terme assez
assez neutres ont volé réfute
on a ciblé la donc les manquements
souligné par la dre elle voulait réfuté
pour nous on a considéré qu'ils
protégeaient l'administration avant tout
et et qu'il a participé aux six est
gérée ambiance un peu délétère notre
encontre
selon le directeur de la dréal la
direction régionale de l'environnement
de l'aménagement et du logement
normandie logistique s'est rendu
coupable de défaillance administrative
après l incendie
l'entreprise mitoyenne de lubrizol avait
mis plus de dix jours pour fournir la
liste des substances qui sont partis en
fumée
jérôme bignon en mots tout d'abord de
cette audition normandie logistique est
elle victime sofitel ses responsabilités
selon vous je n'étais pas cette audition
puisque l'on peut pas être partout au
sénat il se passe ya des conflits de
calendrier permanent je le regrette
parce que c'était intéressant j'ai
participé effectivement assez de
commission denquête parce que je
je suis concerné mon département et
voisins de la seine maritime et la
commune dans laquelle j'habite dans la
somme et le nuage est passé au dessus de
chez nous donc des cultivateurs qui vous
partager les inquiétudes
globalement parce que je suis
parlementaire nationale et que quand il
se passe quelque chose en france ça
m'intéresse évidemment y compris en
france d'outre-mer
mais là j'ai été j'ai été dans
l'histoire du briol parce qu'en plus
nous on est sous le vent sinon on se
dira également des centrales nucléaires
donc c'est des sujets qui me qui me
préoccupe la junte en stationnement
c'est dur c'est pas moi c'est l'autre
donc c'est choquant ça vous choque tu de
tenir sa vente et sa terrible
bon il ya des montants les gens très
content mais c'est toujours un
communiqué la liste des produits qu'on a
un chef d'entreprise digne de ce nom à
des états d état dans lequel les
entreprises qui rentrent doivent être
ceux notés et doit pouvoir fournir
fournir voir déclaré c'est un de ces
produits ils sont dangereux donc
franchement on a fait beaucoup beaucoup
de tort à la réglementation en la
respectant pas et on cause des produits
finalement ça a été affreux ça a été
dramatique etc
mais ça n'a pas été aussi dramatique que
ça aurait pu l'être il ya des
habitations à côté il ya des centrales
kadri ça pouvait être un cataclysme
épouvantable et je pense que ça doit
nous inciter cette histoire de lubrizol
à une réflexion plus globale sur les
sites seveso le nombre de sites seveso
on peut pas traiter le problème sites
seveso par cissé maison il faut le
regarder globalement un peu comme on
fait pour le nucléaire moi j'ai eu je
pense j'ai fait cette suggestion aux
prises d'un mort et on devrait
auditionner je pense qu'on va le faire
le président de l'irsn et ses services
parce que au niveau nucléaire on a une
instance de veille sur ces sujets là et
c'était extrêmement puissante
la cc on est un peu le préfet vient
d'arriver il est pas au courant
il n'a pas le temps de lire tous les
rapports tromper art en moi je joue pour
le préfet certainement de bonne foi fait
son boulot magnifiquement il serait pas
là où il est la pose de préfecture très
important s'il était pas bon donc si je
n'ai pas de doute là dessus mais on peut
pas demander à un homme de faire plus
que ce qu'il peut faire
donc il faut mettre des systèmes en
place c'est pas si on tombe sur un
préfet qui imaginer qu'il n'ait pas été
là c'est son directeur de cabinet qui
s'occupe de ça qui sorti de l'ena
l'année dernière donc il ya un truc je
pense que le respect de la
réglementation n'est pas assurée y'a pas
de réactions assez vives
d'administration quand les délais sont
pas assurés il faut que les politiques
cessent de dire à l'administration
qu'elle enquiquine les chefs
d'entreprises parce que quand elle le
fait elle le fait pour la sécurité de
touche
la réouverture annoncée du site ne vous
inquiète pas non parce que si le de
l'état après ce qui s'est passé
s'il est tard et rouvre sans avoir pris
toutes les précautions
il faut des espèrons serait désespéré
dont j'ai confiance je pense qu'on l'a
fait avec toutes les précautions voulues
c'est on a un état qui a beaucoup de
défauts parce que tout le monde le
critique tout le temps mais en même
temps ça fonctionne pas si mal on est un
beau pays
donc on est en marche à pied tous ont
les sous la pluie on sait pas si
longtemps contraint le lubrizol brûlé
mais globalement ça va pas si mal
eh bien ce sera le mot de la fin oui
vous finissez sur un regard optimiste
germain dominion merci à tous d'avoir
suivi cette émission et à la semaine
prochaine
ciao
[Musique]